well how'd it oh it is so bleeping cold
out this is it's not quite negative 15/4
this I'm a scale of 1 to Antarctica it's
hot right now yeah no no we're about to
get negative hot silver still cold
having just like come here so but we're
gonna watch a movie about the country
the country bears
starring Christopher walk those are the
ways scenes I've seen I've actually not
seen this movie have you seen the actual
movie or if you only seen those scenes -
I I have it's a very interesting
trainwreck to watch unfold okay this
movie was on the side of the road it
would be like a car crash there would be
capers traffic delay everybody would
just be driving by going because super
walk it would be in the backseat all
bloodied up just waving going hello and
then the driver is Chris were walking
from Annie Hall my first viewing his
second I guess of country fairs this is
the lost red state America film TV it's
just like already just know this is not
gonna happen still better than the Jonas
Brothers
a little-known fact that's actually in
sync in those fair casters like New Kids
on the Block where the turtles from a
turtle van yeah this is all still new
kids on the block they went from the
Turtles then they were the country bears
they were also jumping the Holograms
other people don't know and how would
you love to be an extra on that crowd
you got go nuts yeah go nuts with these
bears and half of them aren't even doing
it right
love you freeze-frame it though yeah how
funny would it be if there's just no
music to even listen to there just
pantomiming all this with a bear and
like a violin who doesn't know how to
play a violin terrify I feel like we're
in a spike jonze music video Chris do
you know what he's really there though I
mean it's like the mouth is actually
moving how much work went into getting
that thing to move and talk it's like I
got appreciate that alumina can do they
have a Paddington it's kind of
terrifying because I realize you could
have done that with Paddington looking
at this and you know that nobody cares
oh yeah I I can't love that kid there it
is I'll never be able to discipline this
kid again that's over hey I know the
park just like well he stopped me with
the spoon I guess to become a man that
right there is why I don't take the bus
every once awhile used to get on the bus
it's like well if there's a bear yeah
why did he scratch it now I remember
when I convinced you you were adopted
and then you ran out to Wyoming find
your real parents
he also convinced me I was a bear that
was really fun last year you still
carrying those scars aren't you you
should have figured out those Bears
weren't your parents when they tried to
maul you I cheer up they shot them
that's on you buddy I don't know how
much darker I can make all right this
really isn't the job for us I think you
need animal control please help yourself
okay I this is not good but I'm kind of
know I told you right so far you know
what it kind of has it has a pee-wee's
big adventure feel to it like it's just
so corny and weird and crazy it's its
own and people just kind of accept it I
don't know it's so far I'm a little on
board with it just for how crazy it is
it'd be a beautiful shot you know there
wasn't a Barrett you just go get
damn boy that guy in that suit moved
like that was the last shot of the day
just get through it who knows you are
very Nashville I know that cuz they got
that weird eye of Sauron building how
would you like to be like well this view
that gets a back lot studio tour and
they let you in on the set and you just
have to sit there and be like what are
they filming the boys and I footing on
this reunion show at bear Hall this
Saturday night not even a week to plan
this did you see fire frog give me a
little more time do you know I am rip
pollen that's ours I never said there
weren't a few good jokes in this I'm
just saying a lot of this is kind of
unintentional I know he isn't but I just
wish he was God you have no idea how
much I wish she was in that suit yes
he's almost like a ghost that wanders
into this movie he just seems
otherworldly we do this here concert
[Music]
he's committed to me I haven't seen this
committed since Deerhunter he knows
knows better than probably anybody even
unsaid that the way to make this
funniest is to play it as straight into
attic as possible like a real
wicked villain and like some dark
thriller okay I won't lie anytime they
say I do hate the same here it's just
like watching the country Bear Jamboree
yeah actually stand to move like the
country boo - no no just a minute all
right uh you know it's not an electric
violin so how's it putting up that much
sound this is why I never eat at Denny's
Teddy's would not sound this good they
would tried to do this but they would
not sound this game they wouldn't bear
them they know it wouldn't do this to
get out of giving you good service yes I
like this movie because the boy bears
Ark is so well defined and I feel for
you yeah I know I was like I'm adopted
hey it's country bear Hall hey I'm the
same country bear it does make me
realize that it lose brothers 2004
animatronic bears in it it still won't
work
in fact I'm shocked they didn't try the
house i'ma stop you there though because
I am gonna say it losers mm at both
talking bears and Christopher Walken yes
Christopher Walken should have been the
third blues brother playing the kid
resolved I have a glandular problem I'm
sorry I just had an acid trip that there
was a song sequence I'm so sorry
what just happened was that a minute a
year what what flew by keep you updated
on us watch somewhere you feel like at
some point they're like let's try and
make this an actual movie then halfway
through production they're just like
okay whatever just says how're you want
it's all in the delivery
yeah
whatever I'm funny or he just gives like
blow over for me yeah I agree they run
to the good burger Bosco in the other
way blood like it's not a good movie but
it's so inexplicably bad I feel like it
must have known at least through half of
the production okay we know we're making
something stupid it was like a Rorschach
test for everybody making probably
everybody else brought something
different to the table
yeah that's fair Christopher Walken
obviously thought he was in a high drama
yeah I thought this was gonna be better
than was list dad how they see us I
thought we've come further than this we
need to start our own show about a
modern bear family trying to live in the
suburbs make a comedic also serious from
time to time I'm gonna call it bearish
in a band called the country bears
[Laughter]
there's a greatest waiting to say that
life epiphanies water that's supposed to
be fake vodka all right can we take it
down a bit
[Laughter]
do you remember the movie is it a satire
like you can see
bizarro freakin universe and the sad
thing too I would not be able to
appreciate the insanity of it as a kid I
would just think it's stupid it's like
as an adult I just love how insane
versus favorite salmon pie my hero is
really heroes and my heroes are the
country bears but now I realize all my
idols are dead and my enemies are in
power so this is it okay I can buy most
things in this movie I cannot believe a
kid that listens to country bears also
listens tonight oh my god there's
nothing funnier than seeing a country
bears bus going around in hilarious
circles he's just in there man he's just
in this where you go sit in the audience
well that's a weird place for a country
bear to sit bears don't have to sit in
the back
[Music]
some go up but others down okay I kind
of loved you know it's like the serenity
of bear movie is good but it's just so
insane and it's bad I love it yeah
I feel like sometimes it's intentionally
funny there's a couple jokes I'm like no
they wanted to get a laugh and I got it
and other times it just like it's
unintentionally funny it feels like a
movie where they didn't quite know what
they were going for if they wanted to
play it legit or they want to play
totally insane so they just did
something in between and that mmm
totally that kind of made it more fun
cuz you don't know what I got try like
kind of a weird serious smell there they
just gonna go total balls to the wall
crazy and that kind of made it
unexpected which made it more fun yeah
you're right I don't know if I can say
it's like good but it's hugely
entertaining it's usually entertaining I
have no idea what the intent was but I
had a lot of fun that's about it
bear pun it ain't over bears
you